okay I did a story last week that was
shocking in terms of the reaction
because of how universally positive the
reaction was from 95% of the audience I
can say almost anything on the show and
3040 if not 50% of the audience will
vehemently disagree with me to the point
that they send me insults and troll me
and say horrible anti-semitic things but
last year I said hey you know what I'm
thinking about getting off of social
media
it's totally toxic I've got people with
five followers filling my Twitter feed
with nonsense attacks I don't care about
there's fake drama there's the
anti-semitism there's a very high noise
to signal ratio and it's interrupting my
workday also it's innard interrupting my
personal life it's preventing me from
doing deeper work it's basically become
a nuisance and study after study
suggests it's not very healthy either
psychologically and it was one of those
random not super political in the
partisan sense clips that I often throw
into the show it has about a hundred
thousand views it has 96% likes and
reaction to the clip has exploded in an
almost completely positive way which is
so different than just about everything
we do on the show clearly this struck a
nerve and I receive more emails people
actually taking the time to email me
rather than just leave a comment online
about this story that I've seen happen
with any other story that I can remember
hundreds of emails in just the first
couple of days from people mostly saying
hey David you're you're right left
wingers saying there's very little to
gain from spending more than like the
minimum required time for your job on
social media right wingers even saying
yeah there's very little advantage to
spending all that time on social media
and the most common suggestion that I
received was you know do whatever I want
with social media for my personal life
but there's no denying that for work
purposes abandoning social media
wouldn't be great for the show since
it's been such a help and boost to the
show so the suggestion was
just like make it a very clearly defined
piece of your job set a specific amount
of time for checking into social media
and responding to people which is
basically what I've been doing but I
decided over the last week to become
very very narrow in terms of the social
media stuff and I actually find that
it's making me more responsive to the
things I should be responding to because
I'm not having any kind of overload I'm
checking in on my accounts in a really
limited way
if I see trolling if I see nonsense
stuff that's not of obvious value I
ignore it I mute the people that's that
and one of the really big changes I made
personally is I didn't even remove the
apps from my phone I just removed them
from my homescreen so when I go to my
home screen now I have very little other
than pocket which is an app I use to put
articles that I find interesting there
and just removing it from my home screen
you might say well you open your phone
because you got a text message and then
you decide I'm gonna look at Facebook
it's just as easy to find it from your
list of apps even if it's not on the
home screen but what removing it from
the home screen did is now I have to say
oh do I actually want to go and search
out the Facebook app or the Twitter app
or whatever and just that little moment
of pause almost always leads to me
saying no I actually don't and it has
reduced my time on social media by
probably 90% no intrusions into what I'm
doing and you know what yes some people
will send me a message and I'm not
getting back to them for three days like
over the weekend my life is fine
everything's fine and as far as the work
piece goes I'm checking every social
network in the morning once I'm done
preparing the day's show and then I'm
checking it sometime between 3:00 and
5:00 in the afternoon sort of as I'm
working finished working on the next
day's show and that's it and it's
working really well so so far so good I
look forward to talking to Cal Newport
about this next week on the show he's
written some really good books about
digital minimalism and the distraction
that is sort of ingrained in
to us by these social social networks
and I encourage you to do the same and
if you have questions for Cal Newport
about this either
about his book digital minimum minimum
minimalism digital minimalism or his
book deep work
send him in to me by email why not and I
will talk to Cal about them next week